the Joe Rogan experienced what is
happening with our something happen up
there always at the perch know I read
the perch know this guys are you're
messing with electronic okay um no
there's no approach here yeah okay good
know we have security I would not do
well in a perch you'll be fine dude stay
in this room this room's bulletproof is
it yeah all right good good to know
yeah keep you all right man okay good
are you worried about the perch no are
you worried about the apocalypse no
natural disasters not at all nothing
solar flares taking out the grid no no
nothing I mean there's eggs at alights
going one of the best books no more
seriously and this is my response to
people on the far right and I'm using
that term accurately there's a great
book by Arthur Herman called the idea of
decline in Western history and he talks
about you know every 20 years it's a
different group on the left on the right
and they're like the world's gonna end
and he brings the receipts and it never
ends up happening because people are
smart some and we have a huge asymmetry
in wanting to stay alive so I the idea
that the last of what apocalypse what
pride the Black Plague I would say would
be the last apocalypse we've been doing
so good so far do you know about the
people that got the black pit excuse me
the people that got the black play
because they were eating a marmot liver
so what was it a liver I thought they
thought it was the fleece from the rats
no no no no no there's some recently
recently recently got the black play but
it's the fluids on the rats the last
time that happened in the United States
I think was in the 1920s and that was in
Los Angeles actually the last evidence
of the yeah but you don't die from it
anymore oh you could definitely die from
it but they died in 20s
I think they died in their 20s I thought
it's still okay maybe the people died
this year from the Black Plague ocean
able to date the liver okay
kidney I think right cooling couple you
know you're all marmot kidney yeah
Marmot it's like a vole yeah yeah that's
what used to be 65 million years ago
yeah it's in the museum yeah yeah these
people hate it ate it and wound up dying
from the play what was the point I had a
point about end the world are we worried
about the apocalypse
yeah you know that idea that people have
always worried about the end of the
world and it never happens
sure that's like saying I've always
worried about dying but I never have I'm
not gonna die I'm not gonna die I'm
gonna be I'm not gonna be there you're
gonna die but I'm not gonna be there how
do you know what do you mean how do you
know you're not gonna be there I mean
that's what dying means oh you you're
not gonna be there yeah die so you're
not gonna die right cause I'm not gonna
live were you not so don't even worry
about it there's one over you won't be
here so who cares I wouldn't say so who
cares but I mean if your entire life is
focusing on you know avoiding death and
it's a very bad mindset yeah that's for
sure
that's what I'm saying is that I think
people are operating with a very small
historical time launch and the more I
talk to people like Graham Hancock would
describe the overwhelming evidence is
something pretty severe happened to the
human race around twelve thousand eight
hundred years ago most likely comet
impact or something along those lines
other other people think that it was
actually a solar mass coronal ejections
made lightning storms like rainstorm
that lightning was coming down like rain
all over the world and just killed
everything and this thing could happen
easily at any time not easily oh yeah
easily okay
yeah common impact or asteroid impact
easily thick easily or not easily in
terms of likelihood because it would
have to easily turn in likelihood it
what happened by now no no it has
happened there's a lot of evidence that
it's happened it's just we're dealing
with a small time line the idea is it
could you get lucky and it won't happen
in the next 60 years or so while you're
alive yeah yeah I could have an orchid
hit tomorrow that could happen - okay
I'll take that bet
it's good bet I mean it's good look your
perspective is good that's like it's
good to not worry so to not look at it
because when you have power yeah if you
don't have the power to affect the
combat as I personally don't most room
knowing it's coming who can
theoretically what can I do not it just
live